Bienvenue en Afrique! Ou mieux encore, je devrais dire, bienvenue chez vous.
Parce que c'est ici où tout a réellement commencé, n'est ce pas?
En regardant les fossiles datant de plusieurs millions d'années--
tout met à l'évidence que la vie
de l'espèce humaine telle que nous la connaissons a commencé ici.
Nous serons dans un voyage incroyable pendant les quatre prochains jours.
Vous allez entendre des histoires sur l'Afrique: Le Chapitre Suivant.
Des contes fantastiques et des anecdotes d'orateurs.
Mais je voudrais commencer par quelque chose de différent,
et mettre sur la table quelques chose afin d'assainir l'air, pour ainsi dire.
Quelle est la pire chose que vous ayiez entendue à propos de l'Afrique?
Et ceci n'est pas une question rhétorique
En fait, je veux écouter vos réponses.
Allez-y! La pire
Famine.
Corruption.
Quoi d'autre.
Génocide.
SIDA.
Esclavage.
Ca suffit.
Nous avons tous entendu ces choses.
Mais ceci est à propos de l'Afrique, l'histoire que nous n'avons pas connue.
Les histoires que nous voulons connaître.
et les histoires positives qui existent
Une partie de ma conférence va porter sur les opportunités d'investissement
qui existent sur ce continent.
Afin de distinguer la rhétorique de la réalité, les faits de la fiction.
Pour accéder aux données et statistiques réelles qui existent
sur les choses actuelles qui se passent sur le terrain
qui font de l'Afrique une opportunité d'investissement réaliste et une option ajoutée pour vous.
Alors allons-y parce que l'Afrique,
dans une certaine mesure, est à un revirement.
Un revirement en termes de comment elle gère son image,
et de la façon dont elle contrôle son propre destin.
Et les redressements constituent les parties essentielles
sur lesquelles je me suis concentrées durant la majeure partie de ma carrière professionnelle
Et tout a commencé dix ans auparavant,
en étant un consultant à McKinsey et Company
dans leur premier bureau Africain à Johannesburg.
Et là nous avons travaillé avec des PDG majeurs
sur les questions africaines, et les compagnies africaines en mutation --
faisant de ces compagnies non seulement les meilleures en Afrique,
mais les meilleures au monde.
Mais j'ai réellement formalisé cette discussion sur les transformations
lorsque je préparais mon MBA aux Etats-Unis.
Tout a commencé après un appel téléphonique incroyable.
C'était un appel de la part de Rosabeth Moss Kanter,
Maître à penser et une de mes professeurs à Harvard Business School.
Et elle a dit: "Je voudrais écrire un cas, Euvin--
un cas sur un leader du secteur public
qui a des leçons pour le monde de l'entreprise. "
Et le leader qui m'était venu à l'esprit était Nelson Mandela.
Parce que Nelson Mandela, lorsqu'il a pris le pouvoir
comme étant le premier président démocratiquement élu d'Afrique du Sud,
a eu à faire face à un pays
qui aurait pu glissé dans l'abîme du chaos.
Mais il a commencé à diriger le pays sur un chemin d'un cycle positif.
Maintenant l'étude de cas, "Nelson Mandela: Leader du changement,"
est devenue une base de recherche pour un chapitre
dans le nouveau livre de Rosabeth appelé "Confiance".
Et "Confiance" est devenu un best-seller du New York Times
et tête de liste des best-sellers de Business Week.
Et je vous raconte cette histoire parce que plus tard, lorsque j'ai été interviewé
sur SABC Afrique, sur la chaîne pan-Africane, ils m'ont demandé,
"Quelle est votre leçon clé, ou l'élément clé que vous appréciez le plus?" --
parce que c'était un privilège énorme de faire partie d'un projet de la sorte.
La leçon a tiré est que c'était l'Afrique, une histoire Africaine,
qui avait été utilisée afin de partager les informations avec le reste du monde
pour ce que le point de référence peut être pour les redressement d'entreprises.
L'Afrique avait été utilisée comme une success story!
Donc je voudrais partager une expérience personnelle avec vous
au sujet d'un changement ou une transformation.
Et cela a un rapport avec moi même.
Parce que, en 1994, j'ai emballé quelques affaires dans un sac à dos
et je suis parti pour un voyage d'une année
au milieu de mon cursus universitaire.
Vous auriez du voir la réaction de mes parents!
(Rires)
Mais très vite, je me suis retrouvé dans la partie sud de l'Afrique --
en Afrique du Sud -- à la partie extrême nord, en Egypte.
Et j'ai cherché les endroits les plus insolites.
Je suis allé à l'Oasis de Siwa -- Ceci était un de mes arrêts.
Et l'Oasis de Siwa est célèbre pour plusieurs choses,
mais la chose clé est parce que c'était l'endroit
où est allé Alexandre le Grand
lorsqu'il a voulu savoir ce que son destin lui réservait.
Et d'après la légende Alexandre a parcouru ce désert.
La moitié de son bataillon a été détruit lors d'une tempête de sable.
Et le mythe dit qu'il avait une audience avec l'oracle,
et qu'il prédit son destin de grandeur.
Ceci était en 300 avant JC.
Ainsi, l'Afrique a longtemps été considérée comme l'endroit où aller pour obtenir des réponses.
Maintenant, la chose dont je me souviens à propos de Siwa
était la vue magique du ciel la nuit.
Sans source de lumière naturelle, Siwa est l'un de ces endroits magnifiques
où lorsque vous levez les yeux vous voyez une tapisserie parfaite.
Avance rapide jusqu'en 2002.
j’ai assisté à Cambridge, Massachussetts
à la conférence sur le Développement des Soins de Santé.
Et je vois la même image, mais du côté opposé.
Une image satellite regardant vers la terre.
Et c'est cette image qui a fait un impact profond sur moi
parce que je ne l'oublierai jamais. Je me souviens de ce moment très précis.
Et je veux partager avec vous cette image de ce que j'ai vu à ce moment.
La première chose que j'ai vu a été l'Amérique du Nord pendant la nuit --
lumineuse, dans toute sa splendeur. Une sensation de chaleur. Lumière.
Et puis je l'ai vu -- L'Afrique. Littéralement le «Continent Noir».
Et bien que l'Afrique peut être sombre,
la chose qui a était la plus poignante
était que c'est le défi auquel nous faisons face
mais c'est aussi une opportunité.
Parce que tandis que l'Afrique est sombre -- mis à part les quelques tâches de lumière
qui existent au nord, au sud et dans quelques autres régions --
c'est rayonnant de lumière dans les cœurs
des millions de personnes qui sont là bas.
Entrepreneurs, personnes dynamiques, personnes pleines d'espoir.
C'était George Kimble, le géographe, qui a dit
que, "La seule chose obscure sur l'Afrique est notre ignorance sur celle-ci"
Commençons donc par faire de la lumière pour cet extraordinaire continent éclectique
qui a beaucoup à offrir.
Commençons à le déballer.
L'Afrique est le second plus grand continent au monde, une large terre, après l'Asie.
C'est aussi le second continent le plus peuplé,
avec 900 millions de personnes.
En effet -- pour revenir à la masse terrestre-- l'Afrique est tellement grande
que vous pouvez caser les Etats-Unis,
la Chine et l'Europe entière dans l'Afrique, et encore avoir de l'espace.
L'Afrique est le foyer de plus de 1 000 langues --
2 000 est une autre estimation qui existe --
avec plus de 2 000 langues et dialectes.
Mais vous pouvez dire, "Investir en Afrique dans plus de 1 000 langues,
et ça ne ferait pas une différence."
Que disent les données?
En tant que banquier d'investissement, je suis au carrefour de l'information
et les changements qui sont en train de se mettre en place dans les marchés de capitaux.
Donc je voudrais partager avec vous certains de ces signaux, ou ces signes,
et les changements qui soufflent sur ce continent.
Alors commençons par là.
Et commençons par les choses importantes, les macro-facteurs.
L'inflation, en général, est en baisse en Afrique --
ceci est le premier signe --
plusieurs pays atteignent des résultats à deux chiffres.
Donc commençons à en voir quelques-uns de près.
Je l'appelle mon panier Z.E.N.
La Zambie: de 2004 à 2006, le taux d'inflation passe de 18 pour cent
à 9 pour cent.
L'Egypte: de 16 pour cent à presque 8,4 pour cent.
Le Nigeria, une situation similaire:
de 16 pour cent à 8 pour cent. Des nombres d'un seul chiffre
Plus fascinant, il y a d'autres pays -- L'Afrique du Sud,
l'île Maurice, la Namibie -- tous en un seul chiffre.
Mais ceci est qu'une partie de l'histoire. Vous avez une tendance similaire avec les devises --
des devises passant par des moments d'extrême stabilité.
Mais c'est regarder à la vision d'ensemble.
Et le premier mythe à dissiper est que l'Afrique n'est pas un pays.
L'Afrique est composée...
(Applaudissements)
est composée de 53 pays différents.
Donc la pure définition -- de dire "investir en Afrique" -- est un non-droit.
ça n'a aucun sens.
Chaque pays a une proposition de valeur unique.
Vous pouvez gagner ou perdre de l'argent en Afrique.
Mais les opportunités existent
Et c'est pour cette raison qu'on est là aujourd'hui --
afin de discuter de ces opportunités précises.
Donc commençons par s'intéresser aux pays
et aux matériaux et données spécifiques.
J'ai été récemment élu, comme mentionnait Emeka,
comme Président de la Chambre de Commerce de l'Afrique du Sud aux Etats-Unis d'Amérique.
Et je suis très fier et heureux d'avoir ce rôle
parce que c'est une position fascinante.
D'écouter ce dialogue qui vient juste d'accroître en vélocité,
des discussions à propos de commerce et des compagnies voulant devenir.
Ainsi, le premier port d'escale: Parlons un peu de l'Afrique du Sud.
Mais on ne parlera pas tout le temps de l'Afrique du Sud --
l'or, les minéraux, la première infrastructure mondiale --
un peu de choses différentes.
Par exemple: L'Afrique du Sud a été récemment élue comme étant la première destination
des 1000 meilleures compagnies du Royaume Uni pour les centres d'appel off-shore.
Même langue, fuseau horaire, etc. Logique.
D'autres titres qui ont récemment atteint l'Afrique du Sud
étaient Bain Capital et KKR, les grands de fonds propres.
Les titres en Afrique du Sud: «Ils ont débarqué." Tout à fait inquiétant.
Mais pourquoi sont-ils là bas? Afin d'acquérir des fonds.
L'acquisition de Edcon, un grand détaillant, par Bing Capital est un témoignage
de la confiance qu'ils ont commencé à placer dans l'économie.
Parce que c'est actuellement une longue partie.
Être un détaillant, est une croyance
que cette classe moyenne en pleine croissance va continuer à accroître,
que l'essor et la confiance dans les dépenses des ménages vont se poursuivre.
Mais l'histoire de l'Afrique, et mon intérêt, est au-delà de l'Afrique du Sud,
Car il y a tellement de choses qui se passent.
Sans aucun doute, le Nigeria est clairement intéressant.
Défis -- et nous allons beaucoup apprendre à propos du Nigeria durant ces quatre jours.
Mais en regardant les travaux de Goldman Sachs - nous avons lu le fameux rapport BRIC.
Le nouveau rapport, "le N-11", souligne que d'ici 2020
le Nigeria va être parmi les 10 premières économies du monde.
C'est une opportunité d'investissement. Pensez à ceci.
Est-ce-que quelqu'un -- de nos banques, de nos investisseurs --
est sérieusement en train de penser à aller au Nigeria?
Sinon, pourquoi pas?
Qu'est-ce-qui se passe au Nigeria? Plusieurs choses.
Je veux parler de ça dans la perspective des marchés de capitaux.
Encore un indicateur de tendance.
Guarantee Trust Bank a récemment crée la première euro-obligation
en dehors de l'Afrique, en excluant l'Afrique du Sud.
Mais la première euro-obligation, l'enregistrement de capitaux internationaux
off shore, hors de son propre bilan,
sans aucune couverture --
ceci est une indication de la confiance qui est en train de se mettre en place dans l'économie.
Sans aucune couverture,
une compagnie nigériane soulevant un capital offshore.
C'est juste un signe des choses à venir.
En se penchant à l'industrie du pétrole, l'Afrique procure 18 pour cent
de l'approvisionnement en pétrole des Etats-Unis, plus que le moyen orient avec juste 16 pour cent.
C'est un partenaire stratégique important.
Mettons le Nigeria en perspectives.
De 2,2 à 2,4 millions de barils par jour.
La même ligue que le Koweït. La même ligue que le Venezuela.
Mais avec l'Afrique, commençons à être prudents à propos de ceci.
Et Emeka et moi avons eu ces discussions.
Nous devons nous éloigner de ce qui est appelé "la malédiction des marchandises."
Parce que il ne s'agit pas de pétrole, il ne s'agit pas de marchandises.
Pour l'Afrique pour être vraiment durable,
nous devons aller au-delà, à d'autres industries.
Donc commençons à déballer ceci rapidement,
et je vais passer à travers ceci très, très, très vite,
parce que je peux voir le compte à rebours à travers la montre.
Que se passe-t-il là? L'Egypte.
L'Egypte se lance dans un projet d'une large zone industrielle --
un investissement de 2,8 milliards.
L'annonce est sortie quelques semaines auparavant.
Près de la Méditerranée, à côté d'Alexandrie --
textiles, pétrochimies.
Ce projet est géré par une société de gestion basée à Singapour.
Ils veulent donc émerger comme une puissance industrielle.
dans différentes industries -- mis à part le pétrole.
Regardons l'agriculture. Regardons la sylviculture.
Que se passe-t-il là bas?
En Tanzanie la semaine dernière, nous avons eu le lancement
de la Standardisation des Produits bio de l'Afrique de l'Est.
Encore une fois, rassembler les agriculteurs, rassembler les parties intéressées
en Afrique de l'Est pour obtenir des normes standards pour des produits bio. Meilleurs prix.
Ces normes groupent les fermiers à petite échelle
en termes d'aucun pesticide, aucun engrais.
Encore une fois, une opportunité pour aborder le marché et obtenir ce prix élevé.
Ouganda: la Nouvelle Compagnie Forestière,
replantant et redéveloppant leurs forêts. Pourquoi ceci est important?
Comme les besoins d'énergie sont respectés et l'électricité est nécessaire [nous aurons besoin]
de pôles pour produire de l'électricité.
Mais la cerise sur le gâteau dans cette affaire.
est qu'ils vont profiter de crédits carbone.
Retournons au Nigeria.
Le secteur bancaire a subi une transformation considérable,
de plus que 80 banques à 25 banques. Renforcement du système.
Mais que se passe-t-il là bas? Uniquement 10 pour cent de la population utilisent les services de la banque.
La plus grande population en Afrique est au Nigeria.
135 millions d'habitants. Pensez à ça.
Il y a uniquement 700 de distributeurs d'argent bancaire dans le pays. Opportunité.
De même pour la télécommunication dans le pays.
Maintenant regardons au continent dans son ensemble.
Les gens regardent les routes, par exemple, et voudraient dire,
"L'Angola: 90 pour cent des routes ne sont pas goudronnés. Ah, problème!"
C'est plus cher de transporter les biens. Les prix des biens augmentent.
l'inflation est affectée.
Le Nigeria: 70 pour cent des routes ne sont pas goudronnés. La Zambie: 80 pour cent.
En général, plus de 50 pour cent des routes ne sont pas goudronnés.
C'est une opportunité! Un besoin d'énergie -- C'est une opportunité.
Alors, quels sont les signes qui prouvent que les choses changent radicalement?
Regardons aux marchés financiers en Afrique.
Si j'avais à vous demander, "En 2005 quel a été la meilleure performance d'un marché financier
ou d'une bourse dans le monde?" Est-ce que l'Egypte vous viendrait à l'esprit?
En 2005, le marché financier -- échange de biens -- Egyptien a tourné 145 pour cent.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans certains des autres pays?
Regardons à quelques résultats de 2006. Le Kenya: plus que 60 pour cent. Le Nigeria: plus que 40 pour cent.
L'Afrique du Sud: Dans les 20 pour cent. Nombres élevés.
Ce sont les tendances qui sont en train de se mettre en place.
Mais dans n'importe quelle décision, la question clé est,
"Quel est mon alternative d'investissement?"
Parce que aujourd'hui en Afrique, nous sommes en concurrence au niveau mondial pour les capitaux.
Et le capital global est agnostique - il n'a pas de loyauté.
Il y a un excédent de capitaux aux États-Unis, et la clé est la reprise des rendements.
L'Afrique offre est un jeu de diversification,
et aussi des opportunités pour la remontée des rendements pour l'investisseur
qui est conscient de ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Maintenant en regardant l'Afrique vis-à-vis d'autres choses,
et des pays d'Afrique vis-à-vis d'autres choses,
la comparaison devient importante.
10 ans auparavant, il y avait peu de pays
qui recevaient des notations de souveraineté de la part
de Standard & Poors, Moody's and Fitch's.
Aujourd'hui, 16 pays africains
ont la note souveraine. Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire?
Prenons le Nigeria encore une fois: double B moins
dans la même ligue que l'Ukraine et la Turquie. Nous avons une comparaison immédiate.
L'épine dorsale de la prise de décisions d'investissement
pour les détenteurs de capitaux mondiaux.
Quelques autres résultats. l'Afrique du Sud triple B+. Le Botswana: A+
Le Burkina Faso: B moins. Et ainsi de suite.
En effet, une des grandes agences va ouvrir un bureau en Afrique.
Pourquoi font-ils cela? Parce qu'ils s'attendent que les investissements vont suivre.
Ainsi l'un des indices leader,
et un de mes derniers points que je tiens à mentionner, est
la chose importante que j'ai lu: que CNBC
avait lancé leur première chaine Africaine. Pourquoi CNBC est en train de faire ceci?
C'est la chaine Africaine non stop d'information.
Ils le font parce qu'ils s'attendent que des choses vont se produire.
Vous et moi, les investissements que nous allons faire,
les investissements que le monde va faire --
c'est la chaîne d'information de 24 heures consacrée à l'Afrique.
Donc c'est le changement qui s'est mis en route.
En conclusion, je veux me tourner vers la diapositive précise
qui a eu un impact profond sur moi durant toutes ces années.
Et cette fois je vous donnerai l'image complète de ce que j'ai vu en 2002,
et vous demande ceci lorsque vous pensez à quel rôle pourriez-vous avoir en Afrique.,
pensez à votre voyage en amenant de l'espoir à ce continent.
Parce qu'il y a des opportunités extraordinaires disponibles
Et pensez au concept de changement ou de développement
au fond de vous même.
parce que les choses peuvent changer rapidement.
En 1899, Joseph Conrad a publié "Au Cœur des ténèbres,"
un conte d'horreur sombre le long du fleuve du Congo.
Si l'on regarde attentivement, sur le fleuve Congo
est l'une de ces lumières. Et c'est le fleuve Congo précisément
générant la lumière -- le vieux cœur des ténèbres --
en ce moment même générant de la lumière avec l'énergie hydro-électrique.
C'est une transformation de la puissance des idées.
Donc, la prochaine étape, au cours des quatre prochains jours,
c'est nous qui allons explorer plusieurs de ces idées.
Et peut-être, si vous pouviez toujours garder cette image dans votre esprit.
Et lorsque nous nous réunirons peut-être dans un avenir lointain, en 2020,
cette image sera très différente.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)